the government of the Indian Capital
Delhi is installing CCTV cameras in
School classrooms it says it is to keep
students safe that reasoning born out of
a series of sexual assaults and rapes
against students in schools some
perpetrated by senior school students
themselves some by School Employees and
others by Outsiders
more than a thousand schools run by the
Delhi government are to be covered by
the scheme but its dividing opinion
across the board as DW correspondent
Adil Bhatt reports
foreign
School in Delhi became one of the first
schools to install CCTV cameras in its
classrooms in public areas
every day hundreds of students here are
constantly under surveillance with each
movement of their day being filmed
from the comfort of his office principal
Rakesh dhaya can monitor everything
happening at his school
he says that camera footage allows him
to quickly tackle problems like bullying
and petty crime
something is there okay a warning system
you can say there's some students if
they have some kind of
prank or something to there also this
having the idea okay you are being
watched everything is being recorded So
that adds to that discipline quotient
you don't feel uncomfortable at being
under the Gaze of the almost 200 cameras
in the building
I think
no student would want to be watched by
cameras in the classroom and I'm sure if
you were a student you wouldn't want
that either
so far cameras have been installed in
over 500 schools across the state
concerned with the growing number of
cameras
the Delhi parents Association has taken
the state government to code
today parents Association had aparjita
Gotham and her team are meeting their
lawyer to discuss the case
they are preparing for a hearing in the
coming week
says that live streaming in the schools
jeopardizes the Safety and Security of
young girls and could lead to digital
warism
from the perspective of parents I think
nobody has the right to see if my child
or daughter is studying or not studying
in the classroom
not even parents have that right I see
this move by the Delhi government as
encouraging a culture of live stalking
Freedom Foundation an organization that
defends privacy rights and online
freedom is also critical of the mass
surveillance
Wisconsin surveillance of children also
has a negative impact on their Social
Development so what is happening
essentially is that surveillance of
children is being increased in the name
of making them more secure they're not
getting more secure instead they are now
being harmed as increased security at
the cost of privacy is hotly disputed
around the world
India continues to rise up the list of
countries who watch their citizens more
closely
the debate in Delhi is where the School
classrooms should be the focus of such
surveillance many parents and students
think not
and joining me now for more context is
Dr Sangeetha mahapatra from Giga that's
the German Institute for Global and area
studies and part of Dr mahapatra's
research looks at the impact of digital
surveillance on civil liberties Dr
mahapatra welcome what does the research
say does camera surveillance in
classrooms keep students safe
uh thank you for having me here uh I it
is very different because I have been
studying schools in Delhi in Calcutta in
Bangalore
so while CCTV cameras are becoming
standard practice there is no
standardization of best practices
however in the schools that I have been
to one these are mostly city-based
schools there have been uh The Bullying
come down to an extent in the schools
that I have gone to and interacted with
parents with faculty members with
students themselves
so when it comes to uh bullying
incidents yes to an extent CCTV cameras
have reduced these incidents of stalking
of harassment of bullying I I had a lot
of my uh assumptions also challenged
when I did field work in these because I
assume that students would be uh could
be
would try to change their behavior when
it comes to the cameras inside
classrooms however after point of time I
saw that they got used to it and they
were not that aware of the cameras being
there which was quite revelatory of the
kind of internalization of the
surveillance mechanisms that is
happening so just based on what you're
saying the Delhi government would appear
to have the correct argument that they
are keeping children safe by installing
CCTV cameras in Delhi government schools
is that correct
I would like to give it a kind of a
caveat here because
because you have a reasonable
expectation of privacy that is that you
cannot come and put cameras inside
restrooms or in certain areas that they
consider to be really private
and here this has to align with the
purpose for which the data is being
connected as well as the processes in
place to prevent the misuse of data and
this varies from school to school
I go back to my point about
standardization of practices while some
schools have put in place robust
mechanisms where data cannot be misused
some schools haven't there hasn't been
that sensitization when it comes to how
do you handle that data for how long do
you handle that data who has access to
it for how long is it stored all these
questions are very important when it
comes to especially children when their
data has to be handled with extra care
and there has to be extra due diligence
here right so yes parents are very happy
with the decision of jail the government
that majorities of the parents that I
spoke to
for them it was a confidence building
measure with schools during orientation
when they had this parent Council
meetings
uh just on going back to the point of
purpose and a process and the Digital
Data Protections in India would you say
that the Way digital data is handled and
the protections around that differ to
the way they are differ in India to the
way they are handled potentially in the
west particularly the sensitization
around that
by arrest also there is difference like
in Germany it is pretty good the
standard when it was gdpr are there and
there is also the EU rules when it comes
to the fundamental rights of Digital
Data protection but in India it is lacks
the current digital personal data
protection act uh bill which is this is
third variant till now it hasn't been
passed and it gives God Blanche to the
government there are a lot of wide
exemptions and there are real privacy
concerns that's the first problem we
don't have uh data protection bill at in
place second concern is we don't have a
statutory body of data protection where
people can raise consult secret wrestle
so that isn't there so it's pretty lacks
the data protection act but this is at
the macro level what I would like to
stress here is that when it comes to
schools that's at the micro level and
where they deal with parents and parents
are pretty vocal about their children's
protection at least now and mind you let
me put in one uh information here that
CCTV cameras have become a standard
practice across India from 2017 onwards
for the past six years I have been
seeing this in Bangalore in Telangana in
Calcutta in Mumbai recently in Mumbai
all the 65 000 Civic and private schools
have brought in CCTV cameras
so these are also there but the
concomitant data protection measures
those have not been in place so again I
stress that some schools do good work
they have these control rooms where very
few people have access to the data feed
while some schools just put it in a
reception area where anyone can see what
is happening in the CCTV camera so it's
not standardized let's look at the
search interruptive let's just look at
the non-digital side of this argument
because the government's claim continues
to be looked we want to keep students
safe therefore we need to have CCTV
cameras and based on some of the
experiences that you have had it seems
to be working at least in some schools
let's look at the other side of it is
this also a case of the government
washing its hands of its own
responsibility to ensure that School
Employees protect children
this is actually a very good question
because uh there this also differs from
state to state like in Delhi government
one of the flagship areas is education
and health and here there is this
consultation constantly happening
between the government officials and
schools about especially the schools
that are getting government support
so here the government cannot wash off
its hands of security of children when
it comes to this place because these are
the schools are accountable to the
government and the government is
ultimately accountable to the voters the
parents so in these areas they don't
private schools here anyway have some
amount of autonomy when it comes to uh
safety of children but here too one sees
X for example in Kolkata for example we
see that the municipal Corporation is uh
talking to these schools and trying to
install CCTV cameras outside the
premises to prevent incidences of
violence of crime especially they
started with schools which are girls
only girls schools or co-educational
institutions
so we see mixed picture from state to
state so here so I don't think we can
have a very simple answer here too
certainly a very different school time
to the time that I was in school which
was many years ago thank you so much for
joining us today Dr Sangeetha mahapatra
for that context thank you so much
my pleasure thank you